hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Mario maker contest
is still on I'm trying not to curse and
it's not going too well for me because I
sure do like to say those words that I
like to say I can tell you which ones
you guys know what I'm talking about
you're old enough to understand whoa I
did not look at what the hell this was
supposed to be was I supposed to do that
I probably wasn't supposed to do that
just yet
Oh garish oh oh oh no oh no oh god no oh
no oh well there's not gonna go well for
me I did not read up on this I am so
confused
I imagine that I need to wait for the
p-block for a very specific moment when
my vehicle needs to go through there
which is not now okay so I just gotta be
it's gotta be nice and coy about this so
if I go ah that was good
didn't need it but got it damn it I
probably shouldn't be on this direction
oh crap I need to be in one direction
[Music]
there's a giant fish down there yes
thank you
why'd you do I didn't even know you guys
existed Oh God
okay this dog is exactly not what I
wanted huh oh god oh no oh no not like
this nothing like this okay we're good
we're good
oh hello chip truck think well alright
then I guess that's enough for that I
didn't even need the p-block I think
okay bye then
I approached it okay
whoa I was an interesting woman I don't
even know if I curse at all man
I'm getting to the more frustrated ones
because I put it like hard then medium
hard and then really hard down at the
bottom so don't you worry about a thing
I'll be moseying my way down oh god he
has an evil face no clackum don't do
this to me Blackie hello
okay that's a thing I have this now what
good is this gonna do me oh god I'm
scared
I'm so scared Oh what happened I don't
know what happened what happened what
killed me oh lordy lordy Lou that's not
was probably not oh gosh oh gosh turn it
boogers boogers boogers okay all right
checkpoint that's good hey that means
it's a safe way this doesn't seem too
bad 2.9 system seems so bad no more huh
how much was it but I did it okay oh boy
run run run all right stupid all right
okay okay whoa that was coming at me oh
now I don't have no I don't have my mush
I just have this this doesn't help me
much at all god damn it all right anyway
let's do this
I get it okay heck it on my head I
christened myself King Mario king of the
dirts crown prince of the isness
this is not gonna be easy
am i Kirsten I'm not cursing still like
[Music]
it was sued theory all right got it
okay all right here we go again
you ain't gonna best me oh what's that
miss me oh hey look you didn't get me oh
my gosh whoa hey that's scary
okay goodbye then I'm just gonna carry
on my way
oh no the explosive radius it's blue my
face okay thank you
goodbye now I don't know why the PAL
thing is able to do what it's saying
it's able to do but I've never imagined
that that would be able to be used like
that it really is imaginative I gotta
admit you know while I'm very upset at
all of the things that it's doing to me
Oh God okay ah yes miss G miss miss D
miss D
cookie get in there Oh spin jump spin
jump Oh God my helmet well oh I'm not
gonna get another helmet like that
Oh God moving targets everywhere oh
lordy Lordy oh gosh oh good gosh gosh
lordy Oh Lord Oh God zing it Wow
well wer were okay so it's just a matter
of dodging and being intelligent about
my locale that was not what you would
call intelligent that's just unfair
there's a bunch of [ __ ] damn it nah
[Music]
look there's a helmet that's exactly
what I was hoping for all right perfect
now I know where the helmet is element
can deflect those stupid spikes Oh God
that's not ideal hams hams are so my
hands are sweaty
all my hands every single one of my
hands are so sweaty right now I can't
even imagine man I bet someone out there
wouldn't like to touch my hams right now
well they're just greasy as can be no
one wants to go near my hands
Oh God why has this happened why why why
Oh God
Bulgaria okay okay yeah here we go
yes okay doing okay oh gosh oh gosh yes
yes Wow what do i do what do i do do I
go down there look go down we go down
here go do this see Papa more glaring
too bad in these games
daddy big big daddy mmm markiplier ain't
too shabby at Mario maker so Matt was
the final tally on that one oh that's
that's interesting whatever the number
that is shown up there
so there I go and that's what will be
donated when I pick whatever charity is
said in the comments so the next one is
going to be the super radius that I can
find it'll probably be 2.4 percent okay
yep it'll probably be these two these
two at the bottom of my list here so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and get ready for more money to be
donated to charity in the next video so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next
[Music]